people write into me all the time and I
even have just friends ask me in my
regular lives Michael what do you know
about the law of attraction Michael what
do you know about the secret what do you
know about the crystals and Reiki and
astrology and all this stuff that I say
seems really really kooky and weird but
I don't know anything about it
you do and you say it's not all just fun
and games it gets pretty pretty dark
[Music]
so I
was involved with occult practices for
almost a full decade
um I had an extremely tragic death in my
family in 2014. we touched on this
briefly when we spoke my grandmother
died I was on a cruise ship in the
middle of the ocean when it happened and
she was like my best friend in the world
I grew up with a single mom did the best
she could love her to death but she
could only do so much
um so Grandma really kind of stepped in
and took over
with after school care things like that
so we were very very close growing up
she was my everything kind of in
hindsight she was my god
um
and when she died it was absolute
tragedy for me it was the worst thing
that's ever happened and
once that occurred
um
I was desperate for any way to connect
with her to talk to her again to
experience her again
and I didn't know any better all I knew
was my pain and I know now that Satan
kind of capitalizes on trauma everyone I
talked to that's coming out of new age
doesn't have the same story as me but
often there is a pinpoint traumatic
moment where they've started to go down
this rabbit hole and so
I went to see a medium I consulted a
psychic medium after she passed and the
medium knew things that she just really
had no business knowing it was
astounding at the time
and I was I was hooked I was just 100
all in from that point forward and it
just was a domino effect from there I so
the medium had cards
Angel cards oracle cards as she called
them and I bought that same deck I went
on and bought that same deck by Dorian
virtue who
about five to seven years ago actually
came out and said I'm not selling these
cards anymore God told me that these are
demonic
I can't do this I want to pull back all
of my inventory she had books out she
was like traveling the world she lived
in Hawaii making so much money from
doing this stuff and just denounced all
of it when Christ came to her and so
when I had heard that years ago this is
when I was really deep into it all that
I thought well she lost her mind but
it's kind of a full circle moment I went
out there you had lost your right I had
lost my mind I was I was the kooky one
and so
after I got into cards I wanted to learn
how to develop my own psychic medium
skills so I would buy books about that
and this is all kind of alongside of
self-help getting into like the
self-help kind of culture
that just teaches you off the bat you
know you are your own best asset you you
you you it's all like essentially
narcissistic therapy in all of these
books so I'm doing that alongside
learning about psychic mediumship and
learning about tarot cards and things
like that
um that spiraled into
yoga practice and Reiki because I had
also after my grandma passed decided I
was going to take control of my health
because I was very overweight at the
time I was only 20 21 years old and I
weighed over 260 pounds I was not well
um and I realized I was kind of setting
myself up on the same path as my
grandmother because ultimately it was
her health that did her in
so I don't want to do that anymore
um so I'm learning about self-help I'm
losing weight getting healthy developing
this nice relationship with food and
exercise
and also getting into spirituality so
this is all these moving Parts but the
yoga was originally
[Music]
um
physical wellness like a way to kind of
supplement my weight loss process but
that very quickly became spiritual the
more I read about it and then I became a
yoga teacher years later and that as I
learned about the history of yoga that
just brought me right into Hinduism and
all those kinds of course because people
think yoga is just stretching or
something you know but really it's a
religious liturgy not not just the kind
of Liturgy of liberal white girls in the
suburbs which is what it has effectively
become in America but it goes back much
further and it's a Hindu spiritual
practice the word yoga literally means
yoke and so in that context it's to yoke
spirit so it's an invitation for
the Hindu gods to kind of come into your
body and a lot of the poses are
specifically
um reenactments or paying homage to
scenes with ancient gods and things like
that and I have to pause you for people
who are going to say well that's crazy
that's insane you think you're inviting
all these Spirits in it's just yoga I
guess I would have to ask those people
hey
don't you think it's a little weird that
in your physical stretches as you are
presenting these things to be that you
regularly chant and invoke ancient kind
of Vedic or Hindu utterances isn't that
a little weird that you go into poses
that are explicitly and intentionally
spiritual
what which of us is the crazy one here
because I'm just reading into this
long-standing tradition what it has
already presented always presented
itself is doing right and that's kind of
a misconception a lot of people have
even Christians that I talk to now say
well what what's so bad about yoga
um I challenge you go into a yoga studio
and try and say God's name
you can't it doesn't fit you can feel it
when I was a yoga teacher toward the end
I tried doing it and just
you can just feel from the class it's
like you're not saying you physically
can't utter the words right you're just
saying no one in that place it doesn't
people don't want it right I was even
told because I used to put yoga videos
on YouTube as well and I would try and
say
um you know let's let God's presence
come into the room kind of just when I
was trying to straddle the fence of both
at the time this was about a year ago so
I would get comments people saying I
don't like that word could you could you
say universe
so it's the whole I don't like that word
can you say moloch please right
so the the yogi concept of God is very
much
Source Universe we are all God mindset
and alongside with what you were saying
with the chanting and things like that
it's not just the chanting it's the
poses themselves they're they're very
unnatural it's very different than just
stretching yeah so if you want to
stretch you can do Pilates right yeah
there's no ums and oz in Pilates and so
I always say that yoga is not a physical
practice of spiritual benefits it's a
spiritual practice with physical
benefits so it's just so you got into
yoga you're a yoga teacher you mentioned
Reiki right I've heard this word before
again from my kind of white girl liberal
friends and I to confess my ignorant I
have no idea what it is it's it's energy
healing
so the idea is and when I say these
things now I feel like I just sound
absolutely insane for having believed it
so much
um
so it's essentially
you were able to allegedly able to tap
into the universal energy Universal
Consciousness and how that energy is
supposed to be all love and healing and
so you are kind of the vessel for that
energy to enter in
and you lay your hands over somebody on
usually like a massage table and
you facilitate that energy energy
through their body and you move through
their shocker system which again that
that kind of ties into yoga so the idea
is that we have these seven energy
channels in the body and the throat and
the heart and they all operate different
things for us like where our
insecurities are and our self-expression
our creativity Sexual Energy things like
that and so
for instance someone might say
but having kind of really bad cramps
um can you kind of clear that energy for
me and so you could deduct from that
based on where
the pain is and the shock or Associated
that oh you are probably having some
sort of creativity block yeah I'll clear
that out for you and so that's the idea
and you could use crystals to help
facilitate that because all the crystals
of course have their designated healing
qualities supposedly
um I gotta ask sure
does it work or even
does it does it do anything it does it
definitely puts you in an altered state
of consciousness and that's not just for
the person receiving it's also the
facilitator as well sometimes um I would
have really intense because I would
facilitate it and also receive when I
would facilitate I would get moments
where my hands would get very hot if I
was over someone's throat or something
and that was my cue that they that
needed extra attention
do you think there's a physical natural
explanation for that or no my
understanding
is that
it's
supposed to just be the energy
accessible to all of us
so
we all in a way experience if you're
having creativity Block in a way I am
too so that's why I'm able to recognize
it because we're all one kind of mindset
and to answer a question in regard to
does it work it is a Band-Aid on a
gunshot wound it works until it doesn't
and you need more and you need more and
you need more
um it really for me would alleviate it's
like taking Tylenol it would just
alleviate the symptoms but not
necessarily fix the problem heroin right
and I always say these things are
spiritual narcotics because that's
exactly what they are you get addicted
to it you get addicted to the highs you
know you leave a Reiki session wow I
feel great I feel so refreshed I'm
cleansed and then two weeks later you
have a mental breakdown and you're like
well I guess this chakra is still kind
of clogged or I didn't cut these cords
from my past life sort of thing there
was always an excuse to justify why you
needed more you believed in past lives
oh yeah I believed a lot of crazy things
I was from the yoga and the Reiki
um
I was at this point where again I'm
studying self-help I'm getting healthy
I'm finally at a place where I don't
hate myself when I look in the mirror
because I had lost over 100 pounds
and this was about
six years ago so I'm still sad you know
I thought I had worked through the
Grievances of my grandmother the best
that I could by getting healthy I
thought I'm eating well I'm working out
why am I still so depressed I'm reading
all these self-help books like so many
self-help books you should have seen my
shelves it was ridiculous
um why am I not getting better I'm
journaling every day I'm doing yoga
every day I'm you know if getting Reiki
done I find the people who get into new
age and Reiki and who are really into
yoga
they always seem to read a ton of
self-help books yeah there's a
correlation what's that about uh a
savior complex a self-savior complex
um as opposed to a savior savior right
everything everything is counterfeit
gospel everything all these practices in
one way or another is a counterfeit
gospel
and that is where I'm going to get into
probably the weirdest part of my story
where
I'm up maybe two or three a.m one night
Googling why do I feel
like this why do I feel like I don't
belong why do I feel like I'm almost
like an alien on this planet and so I
find
information journals from people saying
well actually turns out you are an alien
so yeah I literally believe I was an
alien
they're called starseeds
um and the idea is that starseeds come
from
another dimension another star system
another planet another galaxy like I was
mentally ill if you couldn't tell so but
were you mentally ill in you know I
don't know some part of your brain was
firing the wrong way or
or were you just deluded you diluted I
mean this was it was not as though you
know you pop a pill and it fixes a
chemical imbalances like you you had
just gone so far down this Rabbit Trail
that it compounded on itself spiraled
right yeah absolutely
so I'm reading all this stuff and it
made sense to me because it said you
know you've always felt like an outsider
because you are an outsider you don't
belong and you came here to help Earth
so the starseed gospel as I call it is
that
you are kind of a light worker that has
observed the state of our planet
and because coming back to this idea
that we're all one energy the universe
is all one
it's like well if this planet is out of
whack then that's going to Ripple
throughout the Universe and create chaos
throughout the universe so we need to
find Harmony amongst ourselves and so
the light workers from different
galaxies come in to Earth to ascend the
collective that's the narrative
um
and we do that with our healing
modalities Reiki and astrology we teach
these things too so it's obviously very
esoteric indeed but
I guess I
I'm only half having trouble because
I've gone kind of down weird rabbit
holes too which we can get to a little
later
I've never thought I was an alien but
I've gone down pretty weird rabbit holes
but in that moment so you're looking
this up and you know this website says
oh actually you know Angela you're an
alien yes what
how how did you persuade yourself of
that like how would that have worked it
Justified my sadness and it gave me a
purpose because I felt like I was
meaningless I didn't know why I was here
I wanted to die to be quite Frank I was
very suicidal flirted with suicide in
high school on and off in college
self-harm I did all the things and
it never got better you know I was like
25 feeling the same way that I did when
I was 15 despite all the work I was
doing and despite how hard I was trying
every single day to just pull myself up
by the bootstraps and feel good
and just wasn't just wasn't ever really
hitting and what I was really looking
for which I know now was God but
um yeah when I was first learning about
the starseed thing
it was like wow okay this makes sense so
I chose this life I chose to be here I
chose this suffering because it's
teaching me something it's my karma that
I'm working through because when I work
out that bad stuff it helps the universe
with its bad stuff it kind of doesn't
make sense because it not real so
um and it's all kind of self-refuting
because it's like well we're the mess
but we're also the cleanup crew like it
just doesn't really match up like you're
the knot but you also have to untangle
the knot
[Music]
[Music]